so good morning everyone it's not am on
the webcast I'm Alex three contractors
the BTK centers partition center so
today we continue our computing over
there with what i believe is fifty top
introspection I have the distinct
pleasure of introducing dr. Vivian
obvious NIH dr. Bernard he is the senior
advisor for identifying technology and
the common which is what we'll be
talking about shortly
she says on the bd2k executive committee
and leave the variety of data file and
sustainability efforts to the National
Institutes help develop the pics in
molecular pharmacology and computational
biology from the University of
Melbourne's kevin was the senior
associate at the allen hamilton managing
several genome and protein
bioinformatics projects there and back
again achieved surface the program
director for the National Human Genome
Research Institute and what part of the
human microbiome project where she was
responsible for the bioinformatics and
computational elements of that effort so
please join me in welcoming dr. Renata
this morning should be giving us an
insect about the relatively new and
exciting nih common so doctor Naji thank
you for joining us today
the floor is yours right good morning
around next year
Alex thank you for the opportunity to
speak to you today so today I'm going to
talk to a little about the Collins but
also just give you a few updates on
where we are with that which is the
context of this talk today so I'm just
going to you can everyone see my screen
is that the answer to that yes Alex to
you at least
hello can you hear me
Alex can you hear me hello
we can hear you okay great i'm just
trying my slides through it fast alright
so the previous life is just a little
bit of myself lips keep moving so i'm
going to talk a little bit about
biomedical big data
I don't know what all of the audience
the background is i'm going to assume
something in biomedical areas and some
different degrees in terms of data
science i'm going to try and build up a
picture of essentially why you would
need something like the comments and how
we're going to approach it in NH so
studying really added basically all this
is the kind of data at the NIH is it
well known for a lot of it is a lot of
it with analog but it's moving more and
more to digital sciences and I think we
see that some of the examples i'm just
showing here and as we get more towards
wearables and clicking that kind of
information service again towards more
and more data collection as well so i
think this slide is something that maybe
people have seen before which is we hear
about the for being related to Victor
are created several different ones and
that is the volume is in the amount the
velocity which is the speed of which you
need to process this information and
it's coming up very quickly the variety
in terms of the different data types
that we have and then being veracity
which is really the trustworthiness of
the data and its cleanliness can you
really trust it and can you use it
these are the ones without seeing a lot
of nastiness to others that one of the
ones i want to focus on today is also
this which is what I think that data has
value and I think the signal is becoming
digital economy that I think we're all
realizing where in and that data is
really central to that particular
digital economy I think that I'm is
characterized by using data to kind of
business advantage and i think yes
institutions not just commercial
entities are businesses when we come to
data and I think that organizations are
born digital will be at a disadvantage
that
economy so I think organizations will be
defined by the digital assets in the
future and my digital efforts of many
things chance of the sciences that is
data software workflows documentation
journal articles and there's probably
others here as well that I can include I
think these are the ones that most
people which would know about and I
think what's really important here is
that a lot of the most successful
organizations of the future will be
those that can leverage those digital
elected and importantly transformed into
a digital enterprise
how do we put all the pieces together is
the question we have to ask you know we
have the pieces but what do we need to
do i think one of the key ones to make
data central currency of an organization
and its really usable in a digital
ecosystem in the context of where we're
talking about the commons so really the
transactions using data is really want
the commons facilitates i'm going to go
through that little more detail now so
let's have a little bit about the
problem with biomedical data and when I
talked about pitching lessons before I
want to say that include I didn't just
wake up and I think there are lots of
challenges in biomedical data and that
is a metal and a couple of different
categories there is the generalized
article which is still I think the end
goal as many sizes and that's fine
the data which is as soon as a means to
an end is really low value and I think
this the argument was just making before
is that they actually have value and
it's higher than what we're giving it at
the moment the data is not fair and that
is the terms that it's being used fairly
recently i'm assuming but listeners have
heard of disturbed by the don't I'm
implying that it's findable accessible
interoperable and reproducible and have
been a number of papers over the last
two years which talk about this that in
fact if we're going to start value it
has to have these properties here in
order to be able to do something with it
I think they're also has limited
infrastructure to support their data and
I think what the commons was trying to
do is going some way towards doing bash
so here is just a short presentation
which is from the New York health
sciences library somebody might have
seen us it's quite long original
actually quite long i'm just taking a
short abstract on it just sort of
identify the problems with data is real
this little YouTube here really
encapsulate the issues with data only
about a little bit long so I'm going to
play that now the link to the full video
showing here at the bottom of the screen
so you gonna do to you and actually have
a look at that there is enjoy everyone
here will place where you
hello my name is dr. beauty knowing an
oncologist at NYU School of Medicine
however dr. Judy tonight and your
article about be functions it was very
interesting i think that i could use the
data for my work and periodic cancer i
have not an oncologist i know that i
think that could use vegas for my work
on pancreatic cancer so they didn't have
the dated everything you need for nose
of the article know what I need is the
data when you share an alligator
I'm not sure it will be possible that
your work is in personal attention and
was funded by NIH that is true and it
was published and sounds which requires
your data
I just published volumes and i am
requesting your data can i have a copy
of your data everything you need to know
is in the article
no I am
for my dad is but surely save your data
I did I save it on a USB Drive where the
USB Drive it isn't a box it is in the
box at home i just moved but can I
forget it
there are many boxes well I forgot to
label the boxes and you can see I think
this encapsulation a lot of the problems
that we're seeing up with data it's a
small vignette i highly recommend
watching the entire video three parts so
what's changing know what the problems
are but to look at what actually
changing i think one of the greatest
mentioned before which is you should
about making day of fear which is
findable accessible interoperable and
reproducible and it's just shining
clicking here from the Wilkinson paper
that came out about a year and a half
year old your ego that actually start
addressing this has been a couple of
additional papers around this area and I
think what it's doing is really
explaining what you need to think about
when you're dealing with data and the
kinds of issues that you need to be
considering when you're dealing with
data
overall I think this is having an impact
at all sorts of different levels from
institutions like NIH but I know it's
also having an impact across different
government institutions both in the
United States certainly in Europe also
australia and asia i think what you're
going to see is the application that be
to data certainly move forward
another key issues that I think changing
that's hopefully avoiding what we just
saw in that short video is the data
sharing policies from funding agencies
like an edge fact the other agencies
that also deal with data which is making
the data shareable not just uniforms and
making dough fit but also have a policy
saying we want things to be [ __ ] looking
at open data and the standards
associated with that and the things that
go along with grants that are directly
paid by NIH ensuring that data is made
available but I think we're also seeing
a couple other things and that is that
when you store your data that you're
moving towards instead of just having a
local repositories or in general archive
repositories we're actually looking at
now
research data repositories which store
data per se and there are a number of
these that have been coming about and I
think that's also a change in the way
that we're looking at data making things
available in a fair for that but also
having them available to the broader
community rather than just the USB Drive
which is what the previous actually no
sure it showed that the other thing is
metadata metadata is really important in
describing the data that you have and
ensuring that is has quality standards
reality it's really important
there have been many projects that NIH
which should use the metadata but not
particularly well or used community
standards and this is critical for the
way that you actually want to index this
information searcher and make findable
by others and usable by others another
one which is another change that singing
is the use of the unique identifier
ensuring that we have identified as for
the data to say that are consistent and
also it is formulated standards and
standards are spread across this area so
i think we're the youtube video shared a
lot of problems i can hear some of the
areas that I think we're starting to see
some change which is starting to enable
the better use of data and to see value
in the system but I think we're still in
the early days as this and I think it's
important that happened from the ground
up from the PhD students all the way up
to the leaders of the institutions to
embrace these kinds of changes and to
enable that look in their organizations
or even a small level as graduate
students actually do this within their
own work so i think what we're also
trying to get out here is that the first
principles drive data to become the
currency if you actually can describe it
you know what it is it's interoperable
it's reproducible it's basically an
apples-to-apples comparison you can
understand what it is that you have any
we also need to look at policies that
promote the sharing by thick and really
help change that culture which is why i
think the leveraging of their principles
and turning those into guidelines that
the community can use within the context
of their own data really will help
promote this kind of work
so that's right you may go to fear but
there might be what we also need
ecosystems that allow transactions that
occur all that data and improve
importantly for biomedical data you want
to do this its cattle we all know
particularly from genome studies but I
think also from some of the brain
studies when you're looking at not not
just genomic data but also imaging
studies on both things that the data is
large and getting larger and it's quite
cheap to generate the data but it's a
lot of effort on the other end to store
it and also to look at harmonization and
to deal with all these fear concepts so
I think what we want to do is to do all
of these things to look at the way we
handle data in the future so now i want
to talk a little bit about the data
Commons up until now I've just explained
the kinds of things that we're saying I
think much of the community knows that
big data that I've tried to sort of life
there around work about the sort of
pieces around the data problems of the
things that are changing so just mention
what you also need to think about is the
way of platform works here to support
these whole ecosystem and really the
work that's going on in the data
comments really that it's looking at a
platform but for the development of the
digital ecosystem to support
transactions on their data so I'm just
going to talk a little bit about some of
the principles behind the comments as we
see it and that is an urgent mission is
a platform the trust of development of
the digital ecosystem but it trips the
products of research whatever they are
visual assets and as I mentioned before
people with the contents of institutions
in the future we want all these digital
logics to conform to fit principles as i
just said before and we want into
products to exist in some sort of that
share virtual space so then you can find
them deposit manage share we use
essentially do work on this object on
these objects and geoscience and you
want to create a platform to platform to
enable interactions between producers
and consumers of those digital assets
and I think there are many biomedical
finder to produce information that
wanted to be consumed by others and what
we wanted some little exchange do that
it also gives can't adjust to the
digital assets from the people who
develop and support them
one of the big issues is that the papers
are produced can often have P is and
that's important to do that a lot of the
people that do the data scrubbing the
instrumentation some of the software
engineers don't get the kind of currency
that they really need when they're
actually working on the digital assets
and I think papers are great but it
would also to be very helpful and I
think was it good to get current
teachers the digital assets themselves
that whatever they are I think the most
common ones right now that people will
get out data and software and if
somebody developers they get attribution
to that and there's a way to do that
isn't necessarily a paper and I think
we're starting to see elements of that
you say that certainly would get hub and
you see within data repositories that it
just involved in total data particularly
from papers so i mentioned before that
the day comments as a platform
I'd like to talk to you a little bit
more about a platform and it's
essentially a settlement fosters that
development is the ecosystem so let's
talk a little bit about what that might
look like and we're in the family early
days of this so I'm going to take a
quick here from a fellow that I've been
doing some work with here which is
centered poor child he's been looking at
a little capital of the scale this slide
has a link to that I presume these lives
will be made public often they put them
on my future afterwards and you'll be
able to download them and it looks f
platform in the digital space and i'll
explain a little bit but here he's
saying platforms of the plug-and-play
model allows multiple participants the
producers and consumers to connect to it
interact with each other and to create
value and what I think has been looking
at specifically is all these platforms
that if i could show you this icon
you'll identified pretty much all of
them a very classic one is a B&B right
it's a platform that allows producers
and consumers to attract with vacant
apartments houses essentially
accommodation with people who need that
and he's been looking at how those
platforms set up to connect producers
and consumers and what really allows
them to work and one of the business
model behind that
so as I mentioned before but i think it
was studying again that you want
interactions between producers which
instruments to somebody who generates
biomedical data and often the tools but
not necessarily just that wants to be
able to share that information with
others either within a consortium or
with just others in the future you want
to continue that safe there has been you
grasp that they want to submit your
application i want to submit an H so to
understand the data comments platform
and really have my work for biomedical
sciences i'm going to use what's called
a platform step to help visualize this
concept think it looks at it in terms of
the broader digital beginning but I
think it's really important for us sort
of it for the lands that are really
consistent most every single one of
these platforms that he's been talking
about and certainly consistent with the
ones that should be for example for
ovarian cetera
they're really in three minutes is a
technology infrastructure component is
the data component and there's a network
master place community that consume this
information in the context of the data
comments for NIH this is something I've
been working on and the last 18 months
also really looking at okay how do we
look at this this is a platform to
support a data-rich after NH data out
what's the right way to think about it
and this is something that's just a
model of that stack in a diagram of the
structure just briefly yeah so the
bottom layers of Technology this is
where we have a computer file you want
to operate on the day of some form we
are going to leverage our cloud services
and an engine part because we see a
great deal of research is particularly
using large data moving it from
repository to clouds commercial cloud
and actually doing some work on that
some folks analysis and once the
analysis that are moving to the cloud
and they have a result but they
generally doesn't have detectives up
their story trust that too high and
simply moving x to do with encouraging
shimmer costume so we're looking at
what's the right way too
it's the cloud platform to facilitate
the researchers in action saying that
we're also dealing with super beautiful
facility is primarily funded through a
DOA not NIH but we're working with them
to figure out how we can collaborate
essentially what i wanted to go to
technology platform here which is
quality to compute the next layer is
data and we have a collection of DOTA
some of those are from large generated
benefits which is funded by NIH these
are often excellent reference notice
it's there in need
certainly terabyte two terabyte range
generated by NIH usually undertaken
fortunes and with the intent to share
and just some of the examples we can
talk there the encode data sets which we
use on by the community and authored the
check so it's in example 1 i've been
telling you the large hundreds of
terabytes petabytes of data sets which
people want to consume that they can't
do that either locally in their own
systems or at the repository because
they simply don't have the computer
courses to it but we also have
user-defined better in the sense that
people have floated fits that they
actually want to bring to the vice-
perhaps and actually make something else
the bottom layer is that you've got a
whole bunch of data which needs to be
computed against and then the top layer
here is really saying that if you have a
platform with data you want to be able
to do various things to it and the most
common thing that people see if you want
to do some sort of analysis are
scientific analysis but to do that in
these environments you also need to have
a collection of services to enable
interesting that this one is find this
information control indexing is where
the metadata becomes really important
but you also need AP is that can access
the data and you also want particularly
using cloud containers and come forward
that would be say doc containers so
there are a series of services that
enable you to use the center in these
particular environment we need to pay
attention to those as well as the
scientific analysis tools that you want
to use actually operate on the data and
on the top of all of that what you want
is to have some form of interface which
allows you to access the collection of
the notice it's appropriately some sort
of really marketplace to allow those
interactions to drive
innovation the other thing you need to
do is obviously have different objects
appliance and this touches on the third
principles essentially the staff is
three parts sometimes compute a hold of
data from an ancient some form of
biomedical data in general and
collections of services and tools allow
you to operate on that data on your data
if you want more information there's a
link at the bottom of the flight that
takes you to find more detailed
information at the comment if you want
to read a couple of things go to point
out again looking at platforms in
general if you look at this in the
context of some of the way I key things
that the bottom wire is really the
infrastructure as a service and then the
layers around the the data and the tools
around those services in the end the
analytics drilling platform for
software-as-a-service and I think this
is where we're starting to see are in
play certainly in the market we're
seeing a lot of sense providers out
there certainly in biomedical sciences
but you certainly singing in other areas
as well sure a couple of examples of
those in a minute but I think we're also
going to see a dr to damage the service
in the long term because i think really
data is going to be the county to this
and how that looks like I think we were
just starting to understand those pieces
just a moment of a digital art supplies
this is really about making things there
i went to go through this in a lot of
detail i'll just say that there are key
aspects of this that we need what you
need digital object identifier that
result of original sources this machine
readable and you have a beneficial set
that up and you're clear access rules
and entry into things if you do this i
think what that does is it allows us to
move towards fairness essentially this
life was done awhile ago our initial
phase was looking at this and what we've
actually started to do is develop
working groups within bd2k but also
reaching out more broadly across the
community to look at developing fair
guidelines what does that mean anything
into the fit and we are that great i
think started last year it's just
starting to get the scene
purposes to develop guidelines to share
it with the community from examples of
just platform endorsing anything
differently think you're exactly this is
a fast application that a lot of people
to deal with genomics probably not just
connected that allows you to essentially
developed to use pipelines and various
tools essentially either clouds and they
have a lot of genomic data and the
purpose of this company i think is to
enable scientists to giving you generate
scale and it's very much a fight for the
powers of some of the principles i just
showed for the comments
another one is in this example of seven
reduce as well I think they fall into
the same category of any set and as you
notice anyone called social platforms
for the good reasons I believe so i
think what you'll find instances that
accommodates four drives this digital
interface system is the pieces behind it
that enable you to work with that data
so now i want to do is switch a little
bit to talk about the data column pilots
and talk about some of the work that
we're doing an edge for not having all
of it I'm just covering some examples of
that sort of an able to quickly
understand a little bit more about the
concept of the platform and comment so
one of the ones we're working on this
really looking at the convocation at
large and highly utilized and is funded
data with storage and compute
infrastructure is loud and if the
commonly used tools for the analysis and
sharing of those digital objects
the purpose is to create in tropical
resort for the research community
another key factor is the purpose of the
classes just necessary because the data
is large it's also placed for
collaboration and sharing a digital
optics and i think this is one of the
key things that will also found that
researchers often do their else's
opinions cloud because a large data sets
that they often want to share or
collaborate as projects are going on and
collaborated and investigators are
located geographically in different
places across the united states across
the world
so these environments allow them to do
these kinds of collaborations much more
easily and look at the out for the
results delivery together
just want to point out that the parts
that i'm talking about the platform
there are other comments developing out
there and i just want to point out a
couple of these left probably one of the
best buy one is the genomic data Commons
from NCI NIH which is looking at much of
the TCGA data loaded up into that system
that made available exactly the same i
have been talking about a general common
profit but I'm certainly in the last
year or third we've also seen the
emergence of other ones so the Fred
hutch campaneras in seattle also
developing the hashtag comical and the
New York am center of the table has been
developing also your community of
columns is also been working done at NIH
niaid Allergy and Infectious Diseases
Institute developing a essentially in
microbio platforms world for analysis
so what we've seen is the collection of
Commons is happening
the structure is very similar to what i
just described before is the platform's
back all using the basic premise but the
data is somewhat different depending on
what the particular deficits they are
but I think it's important to see if
they all have fundamentally the same
principles and they're all starting to
come together and one of the other
things that how do we connect to them
and i'll get to that in a minute so I'm
going to talk a little bit now about the
pilot but i just want to emphasize this
is just an example the benefits i'm
going to show here and not the ones
we're going to use that just examples of
the kinds of things that we have so it's
just addressed but we are actually
working on the principles behind us and
in sometime early this year the first
quarter will be able to announce some of
the work that were actually doing this
area and some of the specifics around it
so i'm going to take the platform that
just give an example around some of this
so i think what we've got here is we
have a platform so we have a collection
of different clouds that we can use
I think it's important to look at a
variety of different clouds not just one
part because we honestly what a voice a
little of the lock-in but I think it
also
it is helpful for supporting innovation
and competition amongst them and each
one of the systems are different they do
offer many different services that
potentially problem and authored an
opportunity so i think we're looking at
a collection of those which ones we
choose it's going to be dependent upon
things we do based on in these cases the
other thing we're doing is looking at
I'm taking this platform something we
would take a collection of data so here
are just some examples the datasets
which is supported by nih I'm not
playing the big would be the ultimate
ones we use but essentially what we're
creating is a collection of data
different types they don't necessarily
intricately chill out but essentially
you're creating a pool of data that
people could potentially create
individually or across and I think
that's pretty important and from that is
going to company to potentially have a
nice or not and that's the question we
need to look at but i think the pool of
data would actually be quite useful to
consider not so if we take that a little
bit further but we could layer layer on
top of that series of analytics and
services and these are just examples of
how about some of the commercial
someone's are not commercial
some of them are tools some of the tools
system some of the platform's the
service and the global alliances are
they looking at some standard API
securing the data so the collection of
things that already exist out there that
could essentially layer of the tapas
that could leverage the data in a
variety of different forms and provide
access to the rest of the biomedical
community and the only thing that I
think you want to look at is you need to
think obviously that the indexing and
this work being done inside b2k with bio
Kelly which is an indexing system and
biosimilars which is being discussed
with alexia which is the group in Europe
looking at FEMA Doggett applications to
biomedical sciences and I bike has been
heavily involved in looking at those as
well as incorporating a lot of that or
if we could do admit but the key point
I'm trying to make here is that you need
some sort of indexing i'm putting out
these ones here just as example and in
part because we're having a baby
together that true
we out
to leverage the Woodbine hand but it's
really critical that you actually
consider the indexing of that otherwise
what you have a whole lot of data i hold
the tools that I'm not necessarily
easily findable I think that's really
important to actually have your caller
in the system another effect here is how
we can leverage this potentially at NIH
and I think the real key factor is the
the things that we can actually do is if
we make this data are available these
large data sets available in the cloud
and we can layer on the tools i think
there are multiple ways that I agent
foster innovation and so the development
in this area the tools I've laid out
here this around the analytical services
account tools that have been developed
but i think we want to foster more of
that I just give me some examples here
of r1 through written by a grant you
that there are other ways to do this
essentially there are ways to get grass
and managed to foster innovation over
the use of this particular data and I
think we just don't want to do that but
i think what we also want to look at is
considered looking challenges and prizes
why because i think it could be really
interesting to sort of asked questions
across some of this data seems content
to allow us to do that to really kind of
thinking about new ways that you can
actually intersect and ask questions
across the code to enable discovery the
different why you can do that I think
from a couple of different angles one
from a biomechanical one week after an
interesting biomedical question of cost
the financial data sets to improve the
outcomes as a biomarker in some sort of
your discovery better understanding of
the disease all of those irrelevant but
i think what is also relevant is the
services and tools are needed to do that
at a faster laughter right so how well
can you predict that by like it what's
the best way you can actually do that
what are the tools that you need to do
that what's the statistically to do that
those are some of the aspects i can see
that so many challenges and private
should also address that i think could
yield to some pretty interesting ways
that we could leverage this particular
data
I think the other thing i want to point
out is that over the top of this whole
thing you want to have this matter place
which is I think the 10 app store
because that's where people but they
have the best understanding of how it
works with me as an academic work for
the top of data are all within your
system but i think really i'm going to
work the concept of the marketplace
how do we actually have a collection
tools system soda you can easily find
and create a marketplace for the way
that you operate other particular data
fits your particular tool
what's the way to think about that
rather than a single our way to view
your data true one set of tools alone
think that's pretty critical another
aspect to consider about here is what i
call the authorization and
authentication land that is you a lot of
this do with likely to have a human
subject species so some will not the Sun
does so for example human microbiome
notice a lot but many other boats too so
we honestly need to think of the right
way to handle that actually h and much
of the data that's human basis sort of
dig a pit into the I so it is a critical
discussion that happened about how you
set up people for additional educational
in that allows you to get access to that
during the appropriate way and we've
been having complications during that
week an internship house that my
actually could
that's pretty critical so that you can
ensure that only the people that have
committed to the data actually x is that
another thing that I want to point out
here is that this is the only comments
what we're looking at here is nih-funded
data but as I pointed out before there's
a collection of different combinations
that are being developed
I think what's really important area in
stretch we we start talking with them
now
not at the end otherwise we create
cylinders of excellence and that's not
what we watch so I certainly had
conversations with all of the fo'c'sle
appointed shore and there are more and
more folks thinking about this and we've
started discussion
around what the right way for these
pieces to interact and intersect and
where where they separate need to be
separate so obviously one of the match
obviously let's look at it through an
API access point between these
conferences and looking at how we can
run services between them
it's complicated especially when we deal
with human subjects data but i think the
conversation is important point here
that we don't want to simply look at
providing data and creating additional 2
and h and not connecting sure what other
folks already doing in there other
colleges so some considerations I want
to just talk to you now that is metrics
when describing here is essentially a
platform to support biomedical data that
uses cloud data and services but
understanding how and your counsel with
the dough usage is really important
because they will be we need to
understand how it's being used and why
this also it costs particularly for
these large deficits are close to just
not change for the large datasets
particularly want to put them in more
than one cloud and saying that many of
the commercial providers are very
interested in working with us because
they see the value of the platform an
ecosystem that is more than just a
storage so we are you know and obviously
lots of the conversations with him about
the right way to interact is also a for
use cloud compute and there is a project
which is they developed a match for the
end credits model and I'm not going to
speak about that today but it's really
looking at how do you pay for those
services directly inhabited than
actually understand what people are
paying for example when you're using
cloud services a lot of the time you get
free credits from the cloud providers to
say which is great but if you've
probably tried to include everything is
on the cloud in your internet friends
would probably be very expensive and a
type of philly lunch and Brett
there are other issues that we need to
deal with which is the indirect costs
for cloud when you submit a grant NIH
their indirect costs which are selected
with the research institution
I think what we need to look at is the
way that these things obviously interact
and what's the right way to pay for
these and also to do with the
institutions and then let's be clear the
commercial clouds are useful in the
sense that they have scaled that there
are many for accepting that already
developed our private or institutional
best 12 and this is the reason for doing
that cost of one our privacy of data
that's being a lot of concern if you put
this on commercial clouds what's the
right way of handling that it was still
enlisted determining those things so i
think we will see situations where
hybrid clouds really are important and
necessary we need to look at what's the
right mix between those and that's
pretty a very important thing to look at
this look at managing open business
controlled access to the control system
is obviously related to human and we're
going to look at what's the right way to
manage that i mentioned that before the
authorization of potentially to a single
sign on is the way to do that but is
that really a dream or nightmare because
it's what we've seen it's really a very
complicated set that things to do and
there may be reasons we're simplifying
is good but there may be situations
where that's not possible so we need to
sort of test or there and figure out
what's the right way to approach it
it's important to point out that we need
to look at the difference between
archiving this is working and version
copies of the data and it requires that
we keep all our decision-making we act
either that's where a very large icons
like eh
ncbi very important anybody over Europe
and but if we put working copies of the
data into the cloud they are not our
type so we need to know that that's what
we're actually doing
why another one is if we do move copies
of large data sets the cloud obviously
version is dedicating pretty important
so how do we handle that that we too
officials around thinking I think
whatever we doing testing this we need
to figure that out another one which i
mentioned before is interoperability
with other commenters many of them are
going to be based on Cloud 12 inches
before then based on plan and it would
be important to ensure that we don't
have these cylinders of excellence we
actually had probably between these
clouds we have standards around metadata
you might be using the IP eyes and the
key i think here is to reuse what we've
already available talking the community
there is work being done certainly
within bencic a around metadata
templates five nieces group that cedar
there's a lot of work being done by
transcripts with your ID and there's the
Global Alliance which has been looking
at considered API also works being done
within 4 comments smaller efforts
looking at I consented api's that
incorporate meditator and smart and
actually know they can find different
api's locate them so that we have a
better understanding what's available to
us but this is critically important area
that when it
test further developing discoverability
touches on the indexing issue i
mentioned by a caddy before but we need
to look at michaels one place to start a
really good place to have to use but
there are other ways to definitely to
the field is changing for me to figure
out what's the right way to support that
kind of work and particularly if we're
going to have data and digital objects
of various sorts of different cloud
that's going to be interesting
a problem to try and solve as well we're
getting interfaces I think that's really
pretty critical because you've got users
with different needs and different
capabilities certainly in the early
versions of what we're trying to do here
we'll probably the most visible by those
that have a whole lot of bioinformatics
capabilities already and understanding
but we understand very clearly that
biomedical researchers don't necessarily
have the capacity of the time too
find additional group and so we need to
be able to having forces that are
available to biologists don't have those
capabilities that definitely want to be
able to change the data so that's
something we're going to being very
mindful off in all of these pieces
confess this is a really important piece
for getting onto the policy papers here
we consenting of the data may be
necessary and that also could be very
complex particularly if you're trying to
traverse across different data sets that
were consented to be using for the
purpose of using the remaining
prostitutes so we have to be very
mindful those considered in the first
place so engaging with the right folks
to talk about that is really important
something doing that manage their
policies that need to me often
considered in future and giver and that
is the data showing policies that are
useful and effective to support this
kind of open fire we have summary and
personally think we need to focus on
this and there is certainly if it's on
the way I at the nitrogenous and I think
we need more if necessary I think nature
understand that I think we also need to
keep pace with the use of technology and
here exactly a few years exactly did you
get data in the cloud
this is a couple of years ago the
policies and precluding to use something
together in the cloud
this is a big problem for researchers
since they wanted to use that data in
the cloud because they had it was large
and they also had like double compared
against but have policies including is
that and so a group of us including
myself helped change the policies around
that too and I've got the use of you get
in the cloud sometimes happen with this
technology is further ahead than the
policy and we need to do a good job of
making sure that it's just realized and
again it means that we talk in the case
of an HD officer science policy and work
with those people to ensure that they
understand what we're trying to do and
vice versa so we can keep up to to stay
with the changes in technology the
incentives
incredibly important for their sure
ability of fear data as part of the
grant williams criteria as an image but
that I mean when you submit a new
application to NIH you're dismissed all
of your paint that's what it'll be
really good if people could also flight
data and software and any of the other
better efforts of different methods that
you have in a way that's meaningful the
consistent so i think we don't have a
sinner and intentions in there right now
but I think we're really looking at the
fact that if data becomes currency and
say that because currency what's the
right way to include that in the review
system when you're putting their
position to animation we also need to
look at governance which is how do we do
this how do we actually govern the
overall way that we handle comment i
think what's critical here is to have
community involvement in this governance
model that is just generated by an edge
if this is really going to be an open
platform for open science and the
ecosystem to be able to use data at
scale and to share it but I think
getting an understanding from community
involvement is really important and I
think a key one here the last time I got
here my flights of sustainability we all
know that grants have a cycle of an
action and they end so what the
long-term supports is if we do new data
for example in the clouds for something
like notice it
how do we sustain that in the longer
term what's the right business model to
do that and what's the right way to
attempt to do that I think these are all
questions that were we having terms of
what we are trying to think about how we
approach the columns so I think I've got
just two my last life here which is the
acknowledgments and there's a lot of
people that have been involved in this
and I you most
the reason folks to recognize the names
here but my point i want to make out is
that there's a lot of work happening
across NIH that is adjust within one
student across many institutes and in
places that are unusual sort of speaking
and sometimes wanting bios work and that
is our society the center situation
technology and
three nurses group is also the cios NIH
just all the pure computing fried has
been working heavily with us afloat
Common Fund she's very interested in
this kind of work
it's been working with us and enlisted
also the clinical Center is working with
us the image clinical Center to look at
some of their data and also the office
eyes policy so it's a collection of
folks across it and I actually don't
feel like you just have to shout out to
research industry we've spent a lot of
time working with industry primarily
cloud providers that offer these is
provided and also other forts in the
community developing Collins's and
they've been providing really good and
helpful input into the way we think
about the commons so it really is you
find it across international discussions
in places not just across certain
institutes and centers but in places
that would normally be involved in this
that's really touching on the issue that
data is real the currency the way we
have to go to full so i'm just going to
end by just saying thank you for your
time I hope that this has helped you
understand a little bit about the path
we took to the data Collins that we have
some ideas some parts we want to do a
large datasets and in the coming months
we'll be able to explain a lot more
detail around what that would be
essentially what any actually like to do
is to enable the youth and access to NIH
services to the community and the
innovation we hope will come from the
community and how you use those shown up
and how you election develop tools
system services platform etc the top of
that the dosage large and they cost
I think this is where h really needs to
play in the game and we need to help the
community get access to that data so
that we can innovation open the data
science room as well as the biomedical
room so that we can actually foster new
discoveries right i think that i'm going
to stop right now and I think we're
going to take some questions that rip it
is thank you for the incident great
overview for for giving us an update on
what's going on with the end
state of common reaction is quite a few
options for you all of the accessories
of them of service
the first one which have to do with with
the bees that are always associated with
with big data and the somatic touching
on the porosity component and the
question is really given that we're
moving towards be served open data
repositories and public access
information that's been sharing the
information as well people be grounded
into it
how do you have you know that you
contracted it how do we actually get
some grass beautiful right and I think
that comes down to some of the fair
guidelines and making sure that know
that when people apply them what's the
right way we can continue to policing
the winter but we can do that and that's
a complex issue i think if we can agree
to set of guidelines of what Danis
fields and then we can empower ourselves
to use those guidelines i think that's
important i think another thing that we
need to consider is that as people start
using them with more transactions happen
on quality data right they make the
guidelines then the incentive can apply
right so if more people using the
daughter and it's in 15 matches
compliant and you can quote it say for
example an application for an accepted
good day
so there are ways to do that where it's
actually driven in part by policing
policy making and some of it is I think
pushed by the community when we agreed
with standard it makes the transaction
system stronger and datable usable and
what quotable I think it comes from a
combination of two different things and
I think it also comes from the fact that
we don't yet know how to do all of that
but knowing the fact that the data can
be dirty and not quality
I think it's really important to so i
think it allows for a little bit of
willing to say I don't think when you
know yet the entirety of the system
ok I admit you definitely it is it is an
open question is how do we look at that
arm
so following up on master question and
it is another one from regarding the
culture of data sharing and and what are
your perception of where the community
use at as in terms of this new culture
of data sharing i didn't feel that
there's a broad question or growing up
in sweat proportion of finance spending
our researchers do you feel sort of
embracing the data sharing and
participating in it versus those that
are basically going to have to be on
navigated here to view the data sure
well this would be my entire opinion
that's been trying to just it from
couple of different ages my own personal
views that the participants come from a
couple of different regions I certainly
notice that with the younger generation
so the postdocs the questions they
openness the their approach that come
from open so they mindset is open so
they tend to [ __ ] and I think as you go
up the the seniority sexo to fix some of
the pis who are there now to come from
an older generation don't have that kind
of life it so that creates submission
but that's not true of all of them i
think some certainly see the value of it
that the mentality i think has been
changing in the current generation the
ones are coming true now that's one of
the things that I see so as the grad
students are going through the system
and becoming professors within
departments will bring that culture with
them it will take time but I think we're
going to see that and also I think we've
got to the haps enlightened told you are
pretty soon you're in their organization
to also because of trying to push this
through and I think there are plenty of
examples that we see so the combination
was I think of what i say changing i
think the funding institutions play a
crucial role in this and that is that
the funding institutions also have to
provide incentives so as I mentioned
during my talk you need to think about
we and I actually think about the way
that this enters the review system so if
there is an incentive for a digital
asset that has the primarily data or
forwards where the talkers right now
that have for example a deal is
associated with it that can actually be
listed as something very important in
your grant application and that has
value and weight within the way that NIH
sees it when it does review not just
about your paper is all about the other
things that have occurred as well and
their clutches of effective what you
just mentioned before which is well I've
got a bunch of these things and i have
daylight
how do I know that the quality better is
high or not just a bunch of data that is
being with so one of the bars then I
think the application there is how do we
do that and I don't think we know yet we
have to look at it but I think it's
really important that NIH think about
the way that they set up your intentions
for that and they also have policies in
place which I guess that the stick part
of the characteristics where there is
some some level of ensuring that the
community forward for the rules i think
it would be wrong for image to simply
use the stick all the time it would be
good to have both of those in play part
because this lecture the way systems
work and normal humans place it so i
think it would be really good to see if
we can have a combination of the one
that's just sort of like broad general
you what I'm seeing the culture change
i'm certainly seeing it changing more
and more every year I see changes and
that's I think it could think towards
open i think i have would agree with you
on that i think there is it and cultural
change that is happening and it's not
happening no connection at you
differently percolating up arm and in
becoming more common another question on
this is going to some of the comments
that some of the remarks he made
regarding our bio caddy and and other of
sort of effort the president revolved
around 36 being able to find the most
appropriate resources for their needs
and i would spend that that the
respective data and the tools and
software to comment further on other
sort of work that I oakademy or other
groups that you're aware of are doing
teachers help researchers in this regard
sure so I gave him the wide-open field
so I think biochemie has been doing a
lot of work in this area to try and find
wires as investing resources and I think
we're in the early days of that i'm not
going to go into the details by katy and
packages i know it to a certain degree
but I think the question more broadly I
think there's a lot of this was
happening both industry as well as in
research I've certainly seen it with
nvidia to carry that they're a different
platform the way that you might want to
look at discoverability it probably
depends on what you want to find and how
you want to find it and something the
more discoverable and others because of
the metadata sometimes the different
kind of object function find software
sometimes you don't
so there are multiple research and
commercial if it's on the way and I
think what we need to do is to sort of
different back off to see how they work
against some of the data and tools that
we have how does that work and I think
we're just starting to begin that whole
process
I'll give an example from the work I've
done with the notable overage certain in
in Europe they looking at how that they
have with repository also access points
that data and out tool
how can i search for that so what's the
right way to do that and then once you
do find it have you connected with the
surface have you do something with a
bunch of actually found it i think
there's that and then an obvious one of
course is you know Google's really good
at this kind of stuff and all the work
around skin at all which is now being
incorporated by screaming at all i think
it's another effort to look at how do
you leverage ways that methodologies
related to discoverability can be used
in more appropriate ways so
the buy medicine for example I know that
by katy has been moving towards
incorporating a lot of that work within
its I'm debit component so I think it's
a wide-open feel and it's both got
industry as well as researchers
comfortable looking at this and I think
we're at the stage where we really need
to start probing into what are the
different resources are available have a
traditionally and if it doesn't impact
what you're searching for a different is
it doesn't matter which type of digital
life if you're searching for
I think that's currently way we've been
thinking in NIH and I think the work
that we've seen from by Kenya's been
helping us better understand the way
that the communities thinking about it
and as by kevin has been looking at
index finger various benefits we sort of
thing the afterwards though saying well
that would work too
this one works well so that helps the
state back into the system to say what
we need to actually do some pretty
general answer that I think that's just
really where we're at the moment
fair enough i think that that there are
obviously lots of bhk specific projects
that are also looking at indexing often
different perspective i know that
there's 13 ecla and the different
centers of excellence so and and i think
the good thing is that they're all
coming together under one umbrella are
sooo actually there is a question that
was post which is is talking about their
framework arm and the working groups
around that I think I can answer that
for you in this particular case one app
how do you go about finding out more
about their and and joining the working
group other is a common framework
working group of a best that actually
addresses fair and another aspect and I
won't make that information available
more broadly to the community after this
talk of individuals are interested in
finding out more about where the various
working groups that other beings has
mentioned
yeah that would add alex there that
Valentina different romantic drives the
contact person for this from the edge
perspective to yes yes on so one last
question before we go is this have to do
again with let's sort of the platform in
the idea of collaboration envision any
types of practice tool to support after
collaboration are beings are more
corrupted and 14 to collaboration within
our the clouds are not with within the
common things like being able to
communicate and researcher arm so i
guess i do and i think that layer is
often look scene i often by an edge of
the proventil fixture right that does a
lot of connections for good and there
are groups that have pieces of
information that would be really useful
to connect with in this environment not
just the data their offer people that
are developing collaborative tools for
collaboration that allow connections
data to tools for services but also ways
children other things like looking
anything to scholarly research and
scholarly papers journals applications
etc and there are several groups looking
at that and have actually get out some
platforms in this area and I think we
need to look at what that will be the
collars one the way that the development
both collaborative platform speak are a
lot easier for biologists to use i got
was a lower learning proof and the
clouds some extent if it's being used is
keeping in the background but it's still
being used that the whole lot easier for
the people to connect to it if you think
about it that's exactly what the example
they're being be yes you can see
immediately to see the picture what you
want and you can connect to all the
pieces that have only behind the data
cloud all the rest within Google to you
that means that anyone can use that
platform and I do best with the
collaboration pieces into play with the
results they get our enable more and
more people to use these environments
it's going to enable interesting science
after that scale with that with lower
levels of computing capability
and that's fine because many biologists
don't have that what we have to do is
we're right at the start figuring out if
this is what we're looking at the
inconsistent what do we need to test
there's a lot of technology we need to
test before you can get to the place
where it becomes smooth transactions in
the environment that helps
that's great so thank you and Vivian I
know it's an apartment on the west coast
thank you for your time in this
presentation we've had a lot of great
questions and discussion the IC provided
were wonderful
sure i'm happy to take questions offline
I think mine my desktop still have my
email address
I'm happy to take private Christian that
you can find me in different places are
never going to put this presentation of
on SlideShare after this meeting in the
spirit of open sites just making sure
they go to great thank you again thanks
so much everyone
technical death